[Music]
it's me and it is Monday night and the
last Jedi trailer just drop Star Wars
the last Jedi they played it during some
sporting event but thankfully it's up
online so it's all over social media so
let's watch this bad boy man this is the
follow-up to the Star Wars The Force
awakens that was directed by JJ Abrams
this one is directed by Rian Johnson not
to be confused of Brian Johnson from
comic book men we tell you something
Brian Johnson directed this I would hope
that I'd have a part in it
Rian Johnson genius kid behind brick and
lupa I've had him here on a podcast
lovely human being has made a phenomenal
looking movie based on this trailer man
I like the tone of it and I like the
color scheme ie I've seen some people
react like too much information online
though I don't know anything about this
movie right now
you know I think there's a lot of mr. X
I don't think they're telling us
everything but I love what I'm seeing
shall we kick back and watch this
together
god yes let's do it let's dive in shall
we let's cue it up here we go and we
press play
now I'm solo killing [ __ ] kylo Ren just
hanging out
look at his lazy ass bad axe man they
they walk like I do push-ups like like
this
those look like snow troopers there's
our Darth Vader for this generation kylo
Ren picking up his funky ass lightsaber
again
I guess that's snow sweetie
there's reg tracking on the lightsaber I
like the score man intensity an
adventure
there is our boy [ __ ] knockers back
ladies and gentlemen Mark Hamill hey
kids it's Mark Hamill and time to put a
lightsaber on his hands
absolute magic and you put a lightsaber
in her hands as magic - he's scared must
be referring to kylo Ren
that's that vision that was in force
awakens we put the hand on the artena
look at this [ __ ] kylo Ren gets rid of
his helmet somebody didn't want to wear
a mask Gilmour man he's all free face
down stuff this sequence though
number one there's Carrie and she looks
beautiful but if this if they do this
holy crap and then we all gotta go after
kylo Ren not both the pair's hoes Amer
on these are this much more than ten
minutes this time let's try counting
thousand by hey then apparently gets
better Luke well dress Lena someone in
the walk raised in the water
look at all that first order there's a
lady storm pips no offers again walking
on sugar there's no way these two shots
are in the same sequence
he's got flames falling behind her she
doesn't that playing
I'm biometric mark
right
[ __ ] nasty [ __ ] like this makes me
embarrassed that I've ever called myself
a filmmaker as well
oh it's damn good let's watch it one
more time spin through the Star Wars
universe this is exciting
haven't seen you start wars footage in a
while here we go
[ __ ] [ __ ] killed Han Solo lazyadd us
fat-ass
like those notes available I like all
the red man now the posters make sense
it just looks beautiful before but now
it's like what's the matter
mechanical hand spoilers he lost his
hand meddler
[Music]
it's got a real middle-earth vibe
doesn't like Lord of the Rings II tell
him tell Luke my man mark was a big year
for him there he's got he deserves this
yeah and everyone online is like G gonna
be bad hold on let's watch kylo [ __ ]
out and break his helmet man never seen
Darth Vader do that but this sequence
right here Kara judge Mr Justice this is
it that was say it again take all my
money take all my money great trailer
beat maybe they maybe that's a real
thing maybe it's a but I'm telling you
right now man I was already in the bag
for this but I'm gonna buy a couple
tickets to that moment where he's like I
killed my dad do I also killed my mom
some people saying Luke goes bad what do
you guys think
we still gonna have been all the energy
of a shot
[Music]
yeah there's no way those two shots are
in the same room
I'm not saying he doesn't extend his
hands or at some point really but
I think they're taking us out there
great score man
I mean understandable but that that that
score over the tintin tintin to do
that's pretty dope
um okay somebody let's look at some
questions do a freeze frame on smoke
eyes of Emperor Palpatine really I saw
somebody say mace windu as well I don't
you know what don't want to know I hope
I hope they oh I hope they'll if they
tells them this movie great but if they
don't tell us still a third movie I'm
good I think art vast is I think Luke's
could abandon her early on not really
then I lost the threat hold on can I
pull them back down and not really have
a big part until the end of the film and
a larger role in the third I don't know
if that's the case I looks like you know
they're building a lot of the marketing
room around mark I think he's in this
movie a lot more than he was in the last
mode best not saying much it was just at
the end when she was like take back your
dick and he was like maybe credits now
we see him the metal hey and he's like
I'm gonna take that [ __ ] gold enough
wait until he finds out that kylo Ren
killed Han Solo he's gonna have to get
in line behind Chewie man cuz you saw
what happened winning kylo Ren got
killed Han and [ __ ] and Chuy was like
you start shooting them with laser
crossbow yeah there was that cute little
cartoon online that said she we missed
on purpose cuz he pulled the trigger he
thought about all the good times with
young kylo Ren but this moment in this
trailer where it looks like he's like do
I take out my mother that's that's big
huge if that's what really happens the
you know if not great fake you know in
the trailer but if that's what happens
that's that's intense that's drama
that's the Skywalker family drama these
are my soaps kids the way my grandmother
used to watch young and the restless'
and see what Nicky and Victor were up to
every day these are my soaps let's see
Carl Bradley says no way Luke turns dark
people saying that or try to appear
creative bogus well I was one of them
like yeah man he's gonna go dark do I
feel creative let's see
I'm gonna go real-time here Lord is kylo
Ren the last Jedi asks Jambi Cagle I
don't know what were the wolf creatures
somebody said I I didn't I don't know
about that either man I didn't know I
have no answers I don't know anything
about this movie except what you guys
know based on what we just saw Paul
Holmes says I'm really puzzled as who's
Snoke could be if it's just some guy
named Snoke totally he's like you
remember me I'm Snow key I used to live
next door to the Skywalker's back in the
day man I knew old Ben Kenobi I got to
imagine he somebody tied in the unit
into the universe people keep saying
Palpatine but now this would be so in
Return of the Jedi they pitch Palpatine
Darth Vader throws him down ah the thing
and the death second Death Star so this
is years later maybe it is about butene
maybe there's something to that he
survived okay let me see Jack vaziri's
is calling a red herring on the whole
firing of Leia ship to kill her
I smell editing in there as well but man
if they do that in the movie that is
what an intense scene I mean I'm not
like saying man they should have put in
the trailer because I loved seeing it
but like could you imagine you're
sitting the movie theater and you're
like I don't know what's gonna happen
it's gonna happen when I sit in the
movie theater I don't know what's gonna
happen maybe they actually do do it
let's see Larry James Hernandez is your
good hearted guy I wish you were friends
me too
James Johnson says do we think the
story's morphing towards being more
about kylo ren's journey toward bringing
balance to the force maybe I hadn't
thought about that maybe it's like a
redemptive arc the same way that you
know the first three Star Wars movies
were a redemptive arc about Anakin
Skywalker you know falling and then well
he was already fallen when we meet him
but uh you know Luke kind of helps him
redeem himself at the end and stuff um
maybe maybe maybe
more about no way it's about ray isn't
it it's gotta be about ray um maybe it's
about both of them oh my god did we just
literally work this out for ourselves is
that the balance of the force in
question between the two of them let's
read on
Rachel jeantel says Snoke is an ancient
Sith who's been sealed away where'd you
go who's been sealed away for a dick ass
long time is that what all the kids are
saying now dick ass was released during
Revenge of the Sith has been pulling the
strings for Palpatine or so I've heard
where's your information
Cody verdict says Nats the Skywalker
saga it's good point but kylo Ren is a
Skywalker he's the son of Leia and she
was technically I mean wait uncle Uncle
Ben and Aunt Beru were their last names
Skywalker where you get that name Anakin
Skywalker how come her name's not Laius
guy Walker I mean cuz she was adopted
and stuff but once they all figured out
so technically it's still a Skywalker
story Arturo is I'm also this I love
this I love reading people's theories
arturro Coronado says Luke goes dark and
kylo Ren kylo and Rey being balanced by
taking down Luke is is that what you
think it is I kind of take some of my
money man I want to see your version of
the movie be badass now I know some
people out there like now Luke could
never go bad but hey man in the right
hands and I think Rian Johnson looked
like he did a killer job in this movie I
trust him to do weird things with those
characters
Jason McCauley says what if the last
shot the trailer of Kyle's kylo is
extended hand is after he kills Snoke
whom has killed ray and offers his hand
to Luke credits if I was running a
studio I'll just sit on the comments
section
of one of these Facebook lives and just
be like hire that person take that idea
buy that thing
oh my god that's a it's not bad man it's
a hell of an act out let's see Angela
Thoren says I see an alignment swap in
this film Rey struggling to contain her
raw power and being tempted by darkness
while kylo wrestles with his conscience
in f9 we will have read will we have
redeemed euro kylo fighting sith Rey is
that a possibility that rain goes bad
you guys are way more imaginative than
me I don't know why I went into filming
like none of this [ __ ] occurred to me
and I'm the guy used to sit around and
like you know hey man Star Wars F Stark
you know contractor conversation like
guys do deep dives on the [ __ ] I didn't
even think of that badass man they
started with him as a bad guy she was a
good guy then they've kind of flipped
and then Luke had to come in and do some
few help out what if I let me see
Heather Osler says I've never watched
one of these at 35 years old never had
an interest you all are kind of
convincing me I've seen everyone in your
movies a billion times Thank You Heather
but yeah you got look I know you know
it's all new fangled but you got to try
this new fangled Star Wars it's been
here for a while so I mean it's working
for some people I dare say it may work
for you see how excited we all get when
we talk about this stuff and what could
be happening and stuff you could be part
of that speculative specula Tori
conversation but yeah watch Star Wars
man and I'm not having as I do militia
prequels watch them all in his home
right like the end of the day gonna like
walk around and if you got to take a
[ __ ] you take a [ __ ] if you gotta go
cook something you cook some pause it
you can take like 10 weeks to watch six
movies let me see
the only Steven Harris juniors is the
only thing we know about Snoke is that
the witness is that that witness the
birth of the Empire again the star is
animated series
based off Azra why because he must be
stoked you think Ezra from rebels is
Snoke Steven Harris jr. that's not a bad
idea either
[ __ ] [ __ ] you kids are talented
meanwhile I'm just looking at the
trailer go I'm like why did I mad at
slay Z let's call him fat ads huh huh
as I write in better movies than I ever
could
then VIN Craig says I honestly have been
thinking Ray was a kenobi this whole
time because no one else seems to have a
British accent
but this trailer seems to lean into the
Ray as a Skywalker theory I thought she
was a Skywalker at the end of the last
movie a lot of people said why do you
think that I'm like cuz I'm very
imaginative she was handing him his
lightsaber back I thought we were meant
to be like a that's his daughter
giving her the power back but I you know
what do I [ __ ] know apparently not
much cuz it way better ideas going on in
this thread let me see
marika climaxes can you cast me in one
of your films weird before shooting Jay
and Silent Bob reboot and we start
prepping in January start shooting in
February we're supposed to be in
nourlangie more than welcome to join us
we have convention scenes and lots of
creds let me see
Cristian Loki ah no I think look like a
no condom Luke will go bad was written
long ago
there must be balanced with the force
this is there is always an apprentice
and a master but who would be the pro
Rey is the apprentice and then he would
be the master always two there are
ooh Jeremy Estrela got a good theory he
says what if Snoke was the person who
left ray behind on jakku and he's the
one talking to Ray in the beginning of
the trailer
oh I mean I got to tell you I like all
these movies kids
oh my go all your Star Wars flicks
perhaps no more British accents says
Richard Garcia Garcia
alright this go deep cuts here
Jason Fitch go says I think Ray has Ezra
and where'd you go man where'd you go I
lost you I think ray is Ezra and Sabine
wrens child and Sabinas Ben's secret
daughter with the Mandalorian princess
he fell in love with Knights of Ren are
seeking the Kenobi heir I mean I look I
think that's crazy magic too but I don't
know if they would like go deep deep
cuts on Star Wars rebels you know for
for the saga films that requires knowing
something about them but I'd be all for
it and be badass if there I need those
characters have connected but Ezra
that'd be kind of dope
let's see Jeff Gordon Oh says ray had a
British accent because she was left with
unkar plutt as a child he's the guy that
was you know or you walked on poor
people aren't born with an accent
that's good point man it's good point
Rick Mendoza says dude I love that
you're all into this stuff I'm glad you
made it where you did you madam hero you
make movies for guys like this what
thank you um that means a lot
particularly it's been a weird couple
days as you might imagine uh let me see
hey Kevin I gave you that Boba Fett art
a few years back backstage at comic-con
any chance of seeing if you have it up
on the wall somewhere that's in Jason's
office joint he just took it away
because he's got all Star Wars crab in
his office I did literally stole that in
my bag the lure Loreena Hamilton says
these have been skirting on canon
I wonder if the extended universe
starting to pop up and hopefully a new
code or coming eventually that's deep
cuts all right
my phone's telling me my storage is
almost full so I got a dad here but oh
my lord
that was fun go back and watch that
trailer again it's giving me my happy
place tonight thanks for hanging out
thanks for hanging out man may the force
be with you in a minute
[Music]